Everybody, welcome back to the channel.
Today we are going to be deep diving
into Cassandra and this is specifically
going to be through the lens of a system
design interview. And so I'm going to
give you the minimum amount of
information you need in order to present
this information in an interview, but
enough depth such that if if your
interviewer probes, you can justify your
decisions accordingly. So we're going to
try to walk that fine line.
Now at a high level before we get
started, Cassandra is a distributed
NoSQL database and it's designed for
handling massive amounts of data across
many different servers without any given
single point of failure. So there's your
high level summary.
Importantly, it was
created by Facebook in 2007 by Avinash
Lakshman. There's your guy right there.
I'll paste him in. And why is he
important? Well, he's important because
he was also the co-creator of Amazon's
Dynamo. And so when designing Cassandra,
they took a ton of inspiration from both
Dynamo and Google's BigQuery. And so if
you're familiar with either of those
technologies, then learning Cassandra
here today is going to be a lot more
straightforward cuz there's tons of
overlap. We also have a video breakdown
of DynamoDB. I'll put it in the
description. I'll try to put it in one
of the corners if I can figure out how
to do that. And so feel free to give
that video or that written breakdown a
read as well. Now Cassandra was created
specifically to solve the Facebook inbox
messaging system. And so they needed a
database that could handle massive
amounts of write throughput for millions
of users sending billions of messages in
total every single day. And it needed to
be able to scale horizontally, right?
Without manually sharding. It needed to
be able to provide tons of availability
with zero downtime. And it needed to
deliver these super low latency reads
and writes globally. And so that was the
motivation. Now in contrast to
relational databases, which I'm going to
assume throughout this video most of you
have some basic familiarity with,
Cassandra was designed to give up on
flexibility in querying. So there aren't
things like joins or strong consistency,
but in exchange we get three main things
that every massive system needs. You can
see them at the bottom of your screen.
Highly scalable, highly available, and
it's fault tolerant. And so as we go
through this video, we're going to talk
about exactly how Cassandra achieves
each of those things. And at the end,
I'll tell you
exactly how you should decide whether or
not it makes sense to use Cassandra in
your system design interview or not. So
without further ado, let's get after it.
Now that we know why Cassandra exists,
let's talk a little bit about how it
actually organizes data. And so the
Cassandra data model looks a little
different from relational databases, but
there are still plenty of similarities
that you can anchor to. Starting with
the very top, we have what's called a
key space. Now you can think of a key
space just like a database in Postgres
or MySQL. It's simply a logical
container that holds your tables and
defines some global settings. These are
things like how data should be
replicated across the cluster
or how many copies of that data should
be maintained.
Now within each key space, you have what
are called tables. And a table defines
the schema. This would be the columns,
the data types that can be stored. But
importantly, unlike relational
databases, Cassandra tables are actually
flexible, meaning they don't require
that every single row has the exact same
set of columns. And that's as I said
really important. I'll get more into
that in just a moment. But within
tables, you have rows. Each row
represents a single record in the table
and it's identified by something called
a primary key. We'll come back to how
exactly these keys work in just a
moment, but just know that rows can hold
large sets of data and they're grouped
together for efficient access.
And then within each row, you have
columns. These are the actual pieces of
data. And so columns have a name, a
type, and a value. Like in this case,
the name
is name, the type is string, and the
value is Evan. And as I mentioned
before, what makes Cassandra interesting
is that it's a wide column store. If
you've ever heard that terminology wide
column store, it just means that you can
have completely different sets of
columns within the same within different
rows of the same table. And so in this
case, we have user 101 who has just
three columns, name, email, and age,
spelled incorrectly I see.
And then we have a second user here who
actually has an additional column, an
address. And this is fine. Whereas in a
SQL database, you would need to define
this rigid schema and everybody would
need to have an address even if that
address was null, they would need to
have a column for address. That's not
the case here.
We started off by talking about how
Cassandra was built with three
particular things in mind, scalability,
availability, and fault tolerance. So
let's talk about how it achieves each of
these three starting with scalability.
When you're dealing with millions and
some cases even billions of rows, then a
single machine, a single server can't
possibly handle all of that data. And so
in order to scale, Cassandra distributes
that data across many nodes in the
cluster. So that each node stores just a
fraction of the total data set, right?
So in this case, maybe a fourth of the
data ends up on node one, a fourth of
the data ends up on node two, and so on.
This horizontal scaling approach, I'm
sure that's a terminology you're all
familiar with. This isn't unique to
Cassandra. It's how all distributed
databases work, of course. But once you
distribute your data in this way, once
you split the data across multiple
nodes, then you have a critical question
that needs to be answered. Which node
should store this particular piece of
data?
And this is where that partition key
comes in.
So when you're defining a table in
Cassandra,
let me scroll down here to it. When
you're defining a table in Cassandra,
you specify what's called a primary key.
And that primary key is made up of two
parts, a partition key and optionally a
clustering key.
Now if you know anything about Dynamo or
you watched our Dynamo video, then this
is all very familiar to you. Dynamo's
the same. It's partition key and then we
just call the clustering key a sort key
instead.
But the partition key importantly
determines where data lives. So all rows
with the same partition key are grouped
together and end up on the same node,
okay?
The clustering key on the other hand
determines how data is ordered inside of
that partition. So to summarize,
partition key decides where the data
actually lives in the cluster and the
clustering key decides how it's
organized once it's there.
So this makes the most sense when we
have an example here.
You'll see this statement here in order
to create a new table for user messages
in Cassandra. We define our primary key,
which is made up of the partition key
and the clustering key.
In our case, we've chosen our partition
key importantly to be the user ID.
This means that all users or all
messages, excuse me, from a given user
are going to show up on the same node.
This is important because if your query
pattern was to say fetch all messages
from a given user, then now you'd only
have to hit a single node as opposed to
having to query a bunch of different
nodes and then merging or combining that
data together at the end.
And so if we scroll down and we look at
this example, if we've
partition key as user ID, then all the
users with the ID 0 to 10,000, I made up
random numbers here. Just know it would
be some fixed range, are going to show
up on node one, 10K to 20K on node two,
and so on. Now we have a way to decide
what to partition by. But how does it
actually map those partitions to the
specific nodes?
Now the simplest approach would be to
use a hash plus a modulo. And so you can
take the user ID. In our case, user ID
was the partition key, right? So take
whatever value you're partitioning by,
hash it, and then mod it by the number
of nodes you have in the in your system.
This is going to return a number of
either 0, 1, or 2 so that you can know
which one of these nodes it should live
on, right? So concrete example, if our
user ID was 1234 and we hash that and we
got some value like this. This is a made
up value, of course, but maybe you would
use a hash function like MD5. And then
if we took the modulo of that, modded it
by three, then we end up with two. And
so we know that this goes on node two.
This partition should go on node two.
This works, but it falls apart at scale,
of course. And the reason for that is
pretty straightforward and shown by this
diagram here. If you end up adding or
removing a node, then the number of
nodes changes, which means that nearly
every key gets remapped to a new node.
And so in a larger cluster, this would
mean that you're shuffling terabytes of
data around every single time you need
to scale up and down. And so you can
look at some of these simple examples.
If all of a sudden we are now modding by
four instead of three because we added a
new node to the system, then everything
that was previously on two probably
shows up somewhere else now. Right? And
so as a result, we got to move all the
data around. And this is a lot of work.
And so to solve this, Cassandra uses
what's called consistent hashing. And if
you've been
watching any of our content, if you know
if you know anything about distributed
systems, you probably knew this was
coming, right? But instead of using a
modulo, consistent hashing is actually a
really simple concept. It just arranges
all of the possible possible hash values
in a ring. Of course, this is just a
virtual ring, right? But each node owns
one or more ranges of that ring. And so
when a key is hashed, in this case, we
can hash whatever our user ID was, maybe
we get the value 16. Then we find that
value on our virtual ring and we walk
clockwise until we find the first node
and that's where that data should live.
And so by using consistent hashing, this
design keeps data evenly distributed and
it minimizes movement when a node joins
or leaves. And so if database two ended
up leaving now, then everything between
0 and in our case 25 here is going to
end up on database three, but database
four and database one didn't change at
all, right? This is how we achieve that
horizontal scaling. We can add or remove
nodes without disrupting the cluster or
redistributing everything.
Now importantly, this is a very high
level overview of consistent hashing.
Consistent hashing has what's called
virtual nodes, which make this
redistribution more even. If you want to
know more about consistent hashing, we
have a quick video on it. I'll link it
in the description so you can go check
that out as well. Partitioning with
consistent hashing explains how
Cassandra is able to scale by
determining where the data actually
lives.
But how do we ensure that we're always
available and fault tolerant?
The first thing that we need to consider
is replication. Every single piece of
data needs to be written to multiple
nodes. And this is controlled by
something called the replication factor
in Cassandra, where that replication
factor is a setting that is set at the
key space level.
So for example, if your replication
factor was set to three, then Cassandra
keeps three copies of each partition on
different nodes across across the
cluster. And so maybe the original data
hashes to node two, but we're also going
to write it to node three and node four
just to make sure that we have replicas
or backups in case every anything
happens.
Uh these replicas are also they're
placed strategically on different parts
of the hash ring, often times even
across different racks and across
different data centers. So there's a
configuration, which I can't remember
off the top of my head, but it's in the
linked written article, um which
actually allows you to have your
replication factor explicitly specify
that replicas need to be on different
racks or different data centers if you
are in uh a global setup. This way of
course if one node goes down, then the
others can immediately just start
serving those reads and writes. And if
we lose data but or if we lose a node
and it comes back up, then it can just
learn from the uh from the nodes that
stayed online how it should kind of
catch up and repair its data so that it
fits back into the cluster and starts
operating again effectively. Unlike with
many other databases, with Cassandra
there isn't a single leader or primary
node. And and this is pretty
interesting.
Every single replica is equal and any
node can accept any given request.
But if there's no single leader, how do
all nodes end up coordinating? That's
usually the role of the leader in the
system. Like how do you know who owns
what, who's alive, who's dead, um when
things are added to the cluster, how do
we know something was added, when
something's removed, how do we know?
Well, Cassandra handles all of this
through something called the gossip
protocol. And so every node in the
cluster is equal, like I said, there's
no master, there's no central
coordinator, and each node randomly
talks to a few other nodes every other
second exchanging small bits of
information. And so this is small bits
of information like uh which nodes are
up, which nodes are down, what data
ranges they own, what schemas they
should be using, etc. And so every few
seconds they ping these messages to each
other. And if you ping it to just a
couple nodes in the network and then
that node pings it to a couple other
nodes in the network, then eventually
all nodes in the network agree on some
consistent state, right? Over time that
information spreads just like a gossip
uh in real life, and then everybody has
that updated consistent view of the
cluster. So this peer-to-peer design
means that it's fully self-managing and
you can add and remove nodes and the
gossip will just automatically update
the cluster state.
Obviously this is a sufficient
simplification, um but certainly for the
for uh an interview's purpose this is
more than enough information. But this
is how we avoid things like Zookeeper or
etcd,
um which are used in many other popular
distributed systems in order to be that
that central source of truth. But the
benefit is that there's now no single
point of failure for cluster
coordination. So if you've ever dealt
with for example a Zookeeper outage, uh
which would bring down your entire
system, then you know just how valuable
it is to not have that single point of
failure anymore. Now that we've
introduced replication and we've also
introduced that gossip product protocol
for nodes to be able to communicate in
this distributed network, something
really interesting comes up. And that's
that we've created multiple copies of
the same data, which means that those
copies could temporarily disagree with
each other. So imagine that you have a
replication factor of three, you have
three different nodes, you then write an
update to your username, my username
changes from Evan to Evan123. Well, if
that write lands on one node and then
gets propagated to two of the replicas,
then there is a moment in time there
where somebody could read from one of
the replicas and still read Evan as
opposed to Evan123.
And the question that always comes up in
a system design interview is that is
that okay, right? This is the topic of
CAP theorem. So CAP theorem, as a
reminder, says that in a distributed
system, whenever a network partition
occurs, right? A network partition here
of course just means when some nodes
can't talk to each other over the
network, then you have to choose between
two guarantees.
Guarantee one would be consistency. This
means that every single read returns the
latest data, which was not the case in
the example I just gave.
Guarantee two would be availability,
which would be that the system keeps
accepting reads and writes, right? This
is the option that we chose in that
example. And so you have to choose one
of these, either strong consistency or
high availability. There is no both
answer necessarily.
And so Cassandra of course was designed
to stay online no matter what. We talked
about how the core of Cassandra is
scalability, high availability, and
fault tolerance. So it of course
prioritizes availability and partition
tolerance.
If a few replicas are unreachable, it
still accepts writes and synchronizes
them later. That's why Cassandra is
described as an AP system, availability
and partition tolerance.
But here's the cool part. And if you are
in a system design interview and you can
uh bring up this nuance, it's it's the
sort of things that interviewers
sometimes love to hear. And that's that
Cassandra doesn't actually force you to
pick one side, consistency or
availability, forever. It lets you tune
it actually per query. This is what
tunable consistency and and so every
single read and write that you issue to
Cassandra, you can specify a consistency
level. This is how many replicas must
respond before the operation is
considered successful. And you have
three different settings here.
The first is option one. This is the one
that aligns with high availability. And
this is we wait for just one replica to
respond. And so if our partition is
replica is replicated on three different
nodes, then we only need one of those to
respond when we write a write, one of
them can take it, tell us that it got
it, and then we're good to go. And so
this is of course the fastest, but it
has weak consistency because this is the
example that we opened with. You could
still read stale data from one of those
nodes that hasn't yet accepted that
write.
The second is quorum. This is the middle
ground and often times actually the most
popular. And this is that it's just
going to wait for a majority of the
replicas.
And so if you had five replicas in your
system, a replication factor of five,
the majority would be three. And so if
you issue a write, it's going to wait
until three of those nodes have
responded saying, "Hey, I got the write
down." And at that point it'll respond
to the user saying, "Write confirmed."
right?
And then the last one is all. This is
where we wait for every single replica.
And so this is for strong consistency.
Uh so in the case where we need that
consistency, we want to make Cassandra a
CP system, consistent and partition
tolerant, then we would use the setting
all. We're going to wait for all
replicas to confirm that they got the
right.
So with one, you maximize speed and
availability, but you risk reading
outdated data. With all, you get strong
consistency, but if any replica has an
issue,
uh like a network problem, a hardware
failure, whatever it may be, then your
request can't complete. And so most
production systems end up using quorum,
which is that sweet spot or that middle
ground. Before I move on and I tell you
what happens on each write and read
request respectively, let's just check
in and recap what we've discussed so
far. We started with the data model, and
then we learned that partitioning and
consistent hashing is what allows
Cassandra to scale,
that replication gives it the ability or
excuse me gives it availability and
fault tolerance, that gossip and the
leaderless design keep the cluster
decentralized and self-healing, and then
a tunable consistency lets you control
how it balances correctness and uptime
per each request.
Really quick, before we continue, let me
tell you a little bit about the most
popular feature on hellointerview.com,
guided practice.
It's an interactive tool that lets you
practice system design interviews step
by step using that hello interview
delivery framework. You're going to walk
through everything from the
non-functional requirements to the core
entities, API routes, all the way
through to your high-level design and
deep dives, drawing on the whiteboard
and narrating your response, all while
getting real-time feedback on what
you're doing well and where you can
improve by a model that Stefan and I
have spent hundreds of hours tuning.
We've expanded the library to 25 of the
most common system design interview
questions now and we're constantly
adding more. So candidates absolutely
love this feature. I think you will,
too. Check it out at hellointerview.com.
Link will be in the description. Okay,
let's talk about the write path and the
read path respectively. So what exactly
happens when a client wants to write
data or read data from Cassandra?
Starting with writes, when a client
wants to send data to Cassandra to write
to the database, it contacts first any
node in the cluster. This is actually
really interesting. This is different
than most databases where they have that
central coordinator, right? Remember, we
don't have that in Cassandra. So you
contact any node in the cluster and that
node becomes the coordinator for that
particular request.
And so that coordinator figures out
which nodes own that particular
partition key and it forwards the write
requests to those replicas in parallel.
So of course it has all of its internal
memory based on the gossip messages that
it's been receiving to know the full
landscape of the cluster. So when the
request comes in, it can send it to the
right replicas to be able to service
that request.
And that's where this diagram enters.
This diagram here on the right is a
single clustered a single Cassandra
node, okay? And so when that write comes
in, we end up writing that data in
parallel to two different places.
We write it to one, the commit log. This
is just a write ahead log. Uh the write
is first appended immediately to disk.
Note that this is on disk. This is to
guarantee that durability. If things
were to shut down, we were to lose the
node, we had to bring it back online,
then it's important that the very first
thing that we did is we persisted that
write to disk, right?
At about the same time, we're also going
to write it into memory, into what is
called the memtable.
And so the memtable, you can think of it
just like a sorted map of recently
written rows. It keeps everything in
order by the partition key and the
clustering key, and it's fully in
memory. It's It's in RAM, okay? So, this
guy's nice and quick and fast. So, that
makes that right easy and fast.
And then periodically, and this is
asynchronous, right? So, once it's
written to the memtable and to the
commit log, then we return uh back to
the client saying, "Acknowledged, we've
received that right." But then
asynchronously, as the memtable fills
up, it's flushed to disk uh into an
immutable file that we call the SSTable.
This is sorted string table. And so,
SSTables are append-only, they're never
updated in place. And so, instead, new
writes create new SSTables, and the old
ones are merged later through a process
called compaction.
And so, I'm not going to go into a bunch
of detail here, but it is a little bit
interesting, though not relevant for a a
system design interview, probably. Um
but in a SQL database, you actually
change the row. You change the
particular data. If you want to update
your name, then you find that row on
disk and you update name to Evan123 from
Evan.
In the case of Cassandra, you never make
those updates. You just flush this new
memtable, so you have new data. You have
a new row that says Evan's name is now
Evan123.
Uh and that means that
um
you know, every once in a while, what
ends up happening is this compaction
process, which goes through and compacts
all of those old rows to say
definitively, "Evan's is 123 now, so you
don't have to go read all of the
previous updates in order to know the
current state. I'm just going to tell
you the current state because I've
compacted all of those updates to make
reads faster." So,
hopefully that makes more sense. I don't
want to go, like I said, into too much
detail there.
Um
but then finally, when enough replicas
have acknowledged the right, again,
based on that chosen consistency level,
which we discussed a moment ago, then
the coordinator can reply to the client
um and say, "You know, we've accepted
this right. Everything is good to go at
this point."
Um but this is what makes, importantly,
Cassandra's writes so fast. They're
sequential disk appends and an in-memory
insert. There's no random IO. There's no
finding the right place in a table.
There's no locks. There's no
coordination overhead. All of these
things that exist in SQL tables don't
happen here. We simply write to memory
super fast, and we append to the end um
of a log on disk, an append-only log.
Now, reads are just a tiny bit more
involved. It starts off the same. The
client again contacts any node, which is
going to act as the coordinator.
That node then knows which replicas hold
the partition and queries them again in
parallel based on the requested
consistency level.
But then each replica, and again, this
is where we jump into this diagram here,
right? So, then each diagram checks two
places.
It first has to check the memtable in
case it hasn't yet been flushed to disk.
So, it's going to check there first for
any unflushed writes.
Then it's going to check the SSTable on
disk. And so, if it were to just check
the SSTable on disk, it would have to
scan through every single row and try to
find the thing that it's looking for,
and this, of course, would be incredibly
slow. This is the consequence of the
fact that we have this append-only log
in order to make writes fast. Well, on
the other side, it makes reads slower.
And so, Cassandra has some fancy things
that I'm not going to go into too much
detail on, but it has some additional
files in here. One of which is a bloom
filter, and as well as some indexes that
allow you to skip files that don't
contain the partition that you're after.
And so, some bloom filters, some
indexes, makes this read a little bit
quicker, so that we don't have to scan
every single row. A bit more in that in
the written guide, which is linked
below, um but that's how this ends up
working. So, you look first in the
memtable, then in the SSTable, then you
respond back to the coordinator.
And the coordinator takes the results of
all of the replicas and merges them
together, and it picks the newest value
using the timestamp of the right. So,
whichever one is the newest, that's the
one I'm going to send back to the user.
But if the replicas disagree, then the
coordinator needs to perform a read
repair in the background to synchronize
them. So, there's these rare cases where
maybe they were written at at the same
time, but they have different values.
And then we need to figure out what the
heck happened.
Um but in short, it's this combination
of this in-memory caching, this
immutable disk file, these
timestamp-based reconciliations, these
are the things that give give Cassandra
these beautiful properties of really
fast writes, that eventual consistency,
and high availability. Um and it's what
makes Cassandra so great for these
really high write throughput scenarios.
All right. Now, before we wrap up, I
want to talk a little bit about data
modeling in Cassandra because of just
how important it is to a system design
interview.
And that's when you're designing systems
that are going to end up using
Cassandra, you need to model your data
in a way that's going to take advantage
of the architecture that we've been
discussing throughout the video.
Now, if you're coming from a relational
database world, then this is going to
feel a little bit backwards to you at
first. So, let me try to explain.
With relational databases, you normalize
your data, like you see on the left
here. And so, you store each entity
once, usually in its own table, and then
we use foreign keys in order to create
relationships, and we can use joins to
query across different tables, right?
And so, the relational data modeling is
what we refer to as entity-driven,
meaning you think first about entities
and their relationships, posts and
users. So, in this example, we of course
have the post table here. We have the
user table. And if you wanted to query
for all posts and their users, then you
would query the post table, join it on
user ID based on the foreign key here in
the post table to the user ID. But this
ensures that even if we have a post with
the same user twice, it they both still
reference the same row in another table,
right? That's the normalization.
But in Cassandra, we don't have foreign
keys, remember? And we don't have joins.
And we don't even support queries across
multiple tables. And so, normalization
actually works against you.
Instead, data modeling in Cassandra is
what we call query-driven. Maybe I
should even write these down. So,
query-driven
for Cassandra, and then this was entity-
driven, right?
Um And so, it's query-driven. So, you
start by asking, "What queries does this
application actually need in order to
run?" And then you design your table
specifically to answer those queries
efficiently. So, map your query directly
to your table. And this means that
you'll often have to denormalize your
data, which leads to data duplication uh
in order to make sure that each of those
different queries are are as optimized
as they could be. And yes, this creates
redundancy. That is the trade-off. And
that's a trade-off maybe worth
discussing in your interview, as well.
But in Cassandra, the argument would be
storage is cheap, duplication is fine,
but slow queries will end up killing
you, so you can't do that. And so, in
this case, you see that we have a single
post table, but now we've denormalized,
and we've put the user data uh in this
same table. So, that if I want to query
in order to get all posts and their
users, it's a single query to this
table. It's fast and it's efficient. But
you can see that we've stored I guess
this is actually not the
I don't know why that was Jane. There
you go. Now it's John. We stored John
twice here. We have his information
twice here. And that's the data
redundancy.
So, system design interview, if you're
saying you're going to use Cassandra,
but then you design normalized tables
like you would in Postgres, it can be a
bit of a red flag to your interviewer.
It shows that you don't actually
understand how Cassandra works. And so,
be careful. Be sure that you demonstrate
that you're thinking about the access
patterns in this query-driven design.
Let's answer the question that I know is
most important to you guys. And that's
when should you actually consider using
Cassandra in your system design
interview?
Well, I've broken it down here to try to
be as simple as possible.
And that's that you're going to want to
consider using Cassandra when you have
really high write throughput. And we're
going to describe really high write
throughput as something over 100,000
writes per second.
Now, this means that you're going to
have far more writes than you're going
to have reads, and it makes it a good
candidate. And importantly, you should
have predictable, limited query
patterns. So, there's a handful of
common queries that you're going to run,
which are predictable, and you know it's
just going to be those handful of
queries. Things like get all posts for a
user. All right. That's going to be your
main use case, potentially. Then
Cassandra is a great fit. These are
things like activity feeds, time series
data, messaging systems, maybe event
logging use cases, use cases where the
writes are dominated, and you know
exactly where you're going to end up
querying for the data. You can just
denormalize across a few tables, and
each one is going to be optimized for
that specific pattern. Then Cassandra
will scale beautifully, and everything
will work great.
Importantly, there are places where you
don't want to use Cassandra, where it
wouldn't make sense to recommend
Cassandra. And that should be any place,
of course, where you need flexible
querying, things like ad hoc analytics,
complex aggregations. If you have joins
across tables, Cassandra just doesn't
support these things, and so it's not
the right fit.
And then critically, even though
Cassandra has some simple support for
lightweight transactions, these are
transactions always within the same
partition, uh it doesn't support any
cross-table consistency, and certainly
not cross-partition consistency. And so,
uh it doesn't have transactions that
you're used to in an acid database that
can span these multiple tables. And if
you need to write to three denormalized
tables, and one right fails, then you're
left with inconsistent data across those
tables. And so, if you need strong
consistency, if this is a financial app
or a ticketing app or things like this,
Cassandra probably doesn't make sense
for that use case. Great. So, we covered
a lot in a short period of time.
Hopefully you guys found it valuable.
Just to conclude, I want to summarize
what we discussed, and that's this
simple. Remember that Cassandra is
scalable, highly available, and
fault-tolerant. It's great for high
write throughput apps with a few simple
query patterns.
And when you're using it, remember to
consider your partition key. This is
where the data lives. Your clustering
key. This is how it's sorted on each
partition. And then denormalization.
What data needs to be duplicated in
order to support all of your simple
query patterns.
With that, please leave a comment. Let
me know if you have any questions. Let
me know if I got anything wrong.
Uh like, subscribe, all of those good
things. We're going to continue to try
to post one video roughly every 2 weeks.
Um I'll have my LinkedIn down in the
description.
Feel free to follow. Shoot me a message.
Always love to connect with you guys
offline, as well. And most importantly,
best of luck with your upcoming
interviews.